I will succeed eventually if I do not
quit either I will die before I am
successful or I will succeed those are
the variables I get asked a handful of
times on interviews like did you always
know you're going to be successful and
the answer is I thought it would happen
eventually I know that if I keep working
more than everyone else does on a long
enough time Horizon I'll win and I was
willing to give up and sacrifice more
than most people were to achieve that
and so I always thought about it in
terms like what I'm willing to sacrifice
other people willing to sacrifice other
people wanted to have girlfriends some
people wanted to have kids other people
wanted to have you know side hustles
people wanted to follow sports teams
people want to play Fantasy whatever it
I didn't have any of those I never had
the side Hobbies I still don't have side
Hobbies I love business and it's what I
do every day I think it's reasonable for
me to believe that if I do more than
everyone else does for a long period of
time and a very narrow subject I will
get good and if I get good I'll succeed
and so as long as I don't quit then the
only possible outcome besides dying is
succeed